[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday august 5th
i'm cindy yi the spectators broadcast
editor on this week's show
pirates are back this time they're
hacking your computer networks
in return for hefty ransoms i speak to a
former cia man and an expert
who headed up the national cyber
security center to find out more
but in some parts of the world war is
still physical
i'll be reflecting on what the west
still doesn't understand about
afghanistan
20 years on and hearing about why
there's no such thing as the taliban
back home boris johnson and kiyosama are
both in scotland
can they outmaneuver nicolas sturgeon i
speak to our political editors james
forsyth and katie balls
also on the show rory sutherland on
whether delivery discounts will work as
bribes for vaccination
and to send more on whether the trans
weightlifter laurel hubbard
should have competed in the women's
category before we get going if you
enjoy what we do on spectator tv then
subscribe to our youtube channel for
free
click the button at the bottom of this
video and then tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too get 12 weeks of the
magazine for just 12 pounds and we'll
give you a free 20 pound amazon gift
voucher
completely free that's three months of
the spectator delivered to your door
and available online for just 12 pounds
with a 20 pound amazon voucher
just go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
now first would you pay ransom to
hackers
russian gangs are increasingly targeting
western companies and institutions
with cyber attacks stealing their data
and in some cases demanding millions
to give it back in this week's cover
piece kieran martin formerly the chair
of the national cyber security centre
says we need to have a crackdown to
discuss kieran who is now professor of
practice at the university of oxford
joins me with bob bigman the former
chief information security officer at
the cia
who now runs the security company to be
secure
kieran bob thanks for coming on today
now cameron first can you tell us in
layman's terms
what exactly is ransomware and how does
it work
ransomware is digital extortion so you
get extorted in
one or both of two ways firstly
hackers lock you out of your network so
for example
in the case of the federation of 50
london schools
they couldn't get into the network they
couldn't pay any suppliers it couldn't
be any invoices
but also some schools couldn't actually
open because
the gates and doors were internet
controlled and they were locked out of
that
network so the ransom demand is you will
not be allowed back into the network
until you pay us
and that's what you might call classic
ransomware um as
people's backups have improved um the
utility of that
has declined a bit so a second form of
extortion is they then
steal some data perhaps all of it they
will send you back
something they will deem sensitive and
something you'd be worried about and
they'll say we're going to publish this
online
so in the case of the irish healthcare
crisis where
um the irish health body
was subject to a ransomware attack as
well as locking them out of the system
they threaten to post patient data
online for example
so those are the two ways in which you
get extorted
it's been around for years um but it
started really to tick up
about two years ago demands got bigger
more more companies paid
but it tended to be a slightly invisible
problem
companies paid large amounts in secret
what's happened in 2021
is that due to a number of factors
including the increasing recklessness
and cockiness of the
hackers they've started to have really
dangerous consequences that have worried
policymakers all the way to
all the way up to the u.s president so
one attack took out a pipeline
on the east coast of the us leading to
fuel shortages we've dealt with the
irish
healthcare crisis as we speak
you can't book a vaccine around the
greater rome area
because the italian vaccination booking
system has been ransomwared
school attacks in england and new
zealand uh attacks on food retail in
sweden etc
so the real world consequences of this
have become much much more visible
much more problematic and much more
dangerous
and these these hackers they're they're
in it for money are they they're not in
it for geopolitical reasons they're
they're looking for literally fast cash
in my view these people have no
political objectives whatsoever they
just want money they are completely
immoral
all they want is cash or cryptocurrency
more accurately
yes and bob do you see a similar thing
happening in america as well
given that biden is clearly interested
in it yeah absolutely it's it's all
about cash it's all about making a fast
buck and moving on to the next target
and again the targets have no
association with any uh you know
industrial or corporate or geopolitical
point you know it's it's hospitals it's
banks it's all sorts of organizations
and we've had great impact here in the
us as it as as he mentioned
um you know we also also had a death
also associated with a ransomware attack
as well
how say well so a bank i find excuse me
a hospital who is ransom weird
had certain services open for a patient
who was sent there in an emergency
they couldn't use the emergency room
services because they had been
ransomwared and they had locked up that
portion of the network
they tried to move the individual to
another hospital but because they were
in a rural area
it took another you know 40 45 minutes
until they can move them to another
hospital in the meantime on their way
there
the patient died yeah gosh that's
shocking um karen who are these people
we say that they're not political
are they just kids in their basements uh
or are they
organized criminals or are they state
sponsored even if it's the mission if
not it's not political
they're organized criminals and they're
state tolerated they're
so um uh you wouldn't set up
a ransomware operation of the size and
scale that we're now seeing
in the us you wouldn't set it up in the
uk you wouldn't set it up in most of
european union
countries because law enforcement would
kick the door down within
a month or so the russian state and
some other former soviet republics tend
to dominate
um the hosting of these uh criminals you
could see it in some respects as the
latest sort of manifestation of russian
organized crime
and there's an implicit deal between the
russian states and the russian criminal
groups
which is don't attack russians and
russian interests so for example
a lot of the malicious code that you see
is designed not to attack
networks that have installed russian
language keyboards which is really
interesting and telling
and occasionally the state will come and
say look you know so-and-so is a very
good hacker they need to come and work
for the government
and occasionally but this is what we
need to increase
they do something so embarrassing and so
reckless and difficult that the state
puts some sort of pressure on them to
sort of lie low or occasionally will
organize a sort of pantomime show trial
but in effect it this is not directed by
the russian state
but until quite recently until for
example president biden
suffolk to raise it near the top of his
agenda with president putin
there's been no cost to the putin regime
of tolerating this it brings in money it
keeps
quite dangerous people occupied in a way
that doesn't harm the russian state it
irritates the west which is no bad thing
from their point of view but it's it's
not to be confused with the sort of
russian
state um hacks on the us the uk
and and others this is basic criminality
hosted in and around russia
and bob is there anything that
governments can do about
being victims of hacks obviously we're
talking about businesses that are mainly
the victims but is there anything that
their governments the american and the
uk governments can do
back you know can we hack back for
example is that a thing that people can
do
well it you can head back i think it's a
horrible idea
um you know i don't think other than
just
recently uh these these incidents have
reached the national security
uh uh level they they seem to be now
just touching on the edges right of
national security the colonial pipeline
attack was clearly
one that hit the infrastructure then
could impact the national security of
the u.s and did
and did for a short time um but you can
see they
certainly stepped back from that uh and
the russian government was
was quite embarrassed uh internally
uh after that incident so um
they're going to try to solve it from a
policy geo policy perspective right and
try to develop international
norms and standards some of what we did
to the
in the nuclear arms race with mutual
short destruction
i i don't know if that's going to
actually work uh i have my doubts
um but uh short of that i i really don't
know what can be done
at a national policy or geo global
policy level
uh i think this has to be worked out in
different ways
and bob karen writing his piece that as
a business owner you shouldn't
pay these ransoms what do you think
about that i mean it seems like the fast
way to make the problem go away
well but in fact it doesn't um i would
love
i would love that to be the national
policy and have it enforced as well but
that that's not reality
i work with these companies every day
and help them build
you know cyber programs and they still
get they still get hacked they
still get ransom weird and you know
they're not part of the global
geopolitical fight on on cyber war right
they're trying to make things sell
things do things for people and make a
profit
uh it's all about their business and
what's what's important to them
is not what part of the national
struggle they are they're they're
actually
trying to make make money and for them
it's the fastest way is to get back up
in business
and it's to go to the bitcoin machine
and and pay your and pay your dues
and hope you don't get hit again yeah
absolutely and obviously there have been
a small number of stories about people
being hit
twice as well yeah i i haven't seen that
myself
as i said i think you know they're
they're somewhat just really unlucky
and that different gangs basically have
just targeted that same company
more you know more than once but uh
there's no master list
you know that that they all work from
yeah
and karen on cryptocurrency because
that's the often the the medium of
choice for these criminals because it's
untraceable
i mean there's nothing we can do about
cryptocurrency right it's now in the
world
it's it's being speculated upon in the
stock market it's this decentralized
currency
system and once it's in the world we
can't
eradicate it it will still be here and
the criminals will continue using it so
there's nothing
can we do anything about that part of
things i don't claim to be an expert on
cryptocurrency but
a number of cybersecurity i don't think
anyone is an expert on cryptocurrency
they'll struggle to work out the whole
point of it but that's a completely
different
podcast or different episode respected
to tv
i think um but some cyber security
experts and some people with expertise
in
cryptocurrency um would say that there
is more that can be done so for example
the us treasury has had
for more than six months now a draft
rule which has not yet been imposed on
so-called know your customer
requirements uh in other words for any
transaction i think the figure
is ten thousand dollars and you have to
ascertain
some form of verifiable identity before
the money is um
before the money is transferred under
u.s law now clearly there are all sorts
of loopholes and to implement that
effectively would require
um coordination but that's the sort of
thing that we should
be um looking at i think there's a wider
point just on the point on the efficacy
of paying ransoms and i completely agree
with bob that it doesn't solve the
problem and i think one of the most
important things that we need to start
getting
through in terms of the narrative to
victims and potential victims
is that we need to avoid this
pro-criminal narrative that ransomware
is always in everywhere an existential
threat
that if you don't pay you go out of
business that's what's
that that narrative really suits the
criminals and the reality is
it's often more complicated than that
than that if you look at that
um case of the federation of the harris
federation of 50 london schools
they were asked for 4 million u.s
dollars
which they couldn't afford they didn't
pay they undertook painstaking recovery
it was really expensive but the total
bill in u.s dollar term was less than a
million
so just never mind the morality never
mind the fact that ransom paying
ransom's fuels more ransomware demands
just as a business decision it was
cheaper just to recover
so it is possible to recover that
without paying their answers so that's
sometimes
and it's complicated but it's not always
an everywhere pay up or go out of
business
and we need to stop saying that because
that suits the criminals that narrative
is what they want people to think
kira martin bob bigman thanks for
joining spectator tv
now from a new war to an old one the
west mission in afghanistan was clearly
a failure but what exactly went wrong as
former british defense ministers
campaigned for greater support of
afghans who helped the war effort
andy owen a former intelligence officer
who spent time in the country
writes in this week's issue that the
west never understood afghanistan enough
he joins me on spectator tv now together
with dr mike martin
who spent two years as a british army
officer in helmand
andy mike thanks for coming on now andy
you write about the lessons we learned
from our war in afghanistan
and that when you were there you saw
there was no clear or measurable
strategy
what was that like on the ground before
sort of the answer about the strategy
i think when we're talking about
afghanistan at the moment it's really
important to recognize
the 40 000 at least afghan civilians
who've died the 3
500 coalition troops 450 of them
british who died as well as the acts of
bravery
that were committed there as well and
and recognized that
it is really tough to talk about the
failures um because certainly
um the the relatives who had loved ones
who have died there do not want to feel
that they
died in vain but it is really important
to recognize the failures and we owe it
to
the next generation of soldiers and the
next generation of civilians
who may be impacted if we make the same
mistakes again
and for me one of the biggest mistakes
was that that that lack of a clear
measurable consist consistent strategy
on the on the ground in afghanistan and
there's
one good example to illustrate that was
um one day sitting in the in the
headquarters in
um of the coalition down in um in
helmand in lashkuga
uh the the brigade commander had been
visiting a district uh only the day
before
and had been talking to some of the
farmers there who were growing opium
and he had assured them he wasn't
interested in their opium he was
interested
in in dealing with the with the taliban
there and if they didn't support the
taliban he wouldn't touch their opium
and then the next day when we were
sitting there a task force from kabul
flew down
in in their white hind helicopters
landed
sponsored by the foreign office and
destroyed the opium crop there because
they were part of the canton narcotics
task force and our strategy at different
points was focused on
trying to originally get rid of the the
architects behind 911 it was then
also trying to get rid of the taliban it
was dealing with the opium problem there
trying to cut off the opium supplies
and then ultimately sort of driven by a
flawed and hubristic ideology
trying to give the non-existent nation
state of afghanistan a western liberal
democracy and and supplant that on a
very different culture that had its had
its own system of governance and
and really a very local tribal based way
of
interacting and mike this is something
that you've picked up on
as well in the past you've written about
how the brass was funneling money into
the afghan government
as well as into the pakistan government
and you point out that this is a
ridiculous strategy can you talk us
through
why that's so contradictory
uh sure well the uh uh
obviously afghanistan and pakistan are
neighbors and they share a border
that the brits in fact drew in in 1893
and um it's it's
pretty commonly accepted that the
pakistani government and
particularly the pakistani military
supports the
afghan taliban and they support them
uh militarily with supplies but also
with advisers
and and with a rest area you know you
can go back across the border
your family are safe perhaps you can go
to hospital if you've been injured
so you know the pakistani state we need
to be very clear
um are a major supporter of the afghan
taliban
now of course pakistan is
a poor country and it's also a strategic
and important country
and so over the last 50 years but let's
just deal with it since 9 11 over the
last 20 years
america and the brits and other
countries
have funneled billions of dollars into
pakistan
in the way of you know development
projects but also in the way of kind of
arms deals so we've
sold them weapons and we've given them
weapons and some of that is because
they've been conducting operations in
their own countries but of course there
is
inevitably leakage so you know to come
back to the point of your question
we have spent the last 20 years in
afghanistan supporting the afghan
government
to fight the taliban who are an
insurgent movement who threatened that
government
but at exactly the same time we have
been
paying billions of dollars to the
pakistani government
whilst they have been sending that money
back across the border to the afghan
taliban
who have then used it to blow up british
soldiers
and that sounds like a very
bold way of stating that but that's
exactly
what has been happening british
government money american government
money
has been through this cycle via the
pakistani government
via groups that we lump together and we
call the afghan taliban
and have been blowing up british and
american soldiers
and to us that seems utterly insane
well to the helmandes where we were
where andy and i were in the south the
country or see afghans
it is beyond insane and so
they try and explain
this evidence that they have in front of
them and the only way
that they can explain this evidence is
is they come to the following conclusion
they conclude
that the brits and the americans are
working with the pakistanis and the
taliban
to destroy the afghan states
and this sounds like a crazy conspiracy
theory indeed when i first heard it i
thought wow this is up there with uh
you know 911 didn't happen or the moon
landings were faked
it is a very very very
common idea or concept that afghans have
that explains the last 20 years of the
war in afghanistan
that's fascinating mike andy how much do
you think that the west
understands what those conversations are
happening
on the ground between afghan people like
how much um
is our failure down to a lack of
understanding of the afghan history
culture
and what is happening on the ground i
think it's a very significant part part
of our failure
i think it um i think we had very little
understanding of the
underlying culture i think if you just
look at
how difficult it was to even communicate
with um
the people we were interacting with very
very few people spoke the
the local language pashtun down there um
we struggle to find military
interpreters
um i think we'll struggle to find
military interpreters again in the
future because of the way we've treated
some of the
afghans who did work for us and
we didn't understand the the the the
many many local conflicts that we were
getting involved in
there was some of the the the wider
strategy that mike has
has uh very clearly outlined there that
i think we are ignorant to but also
on a very local level we were sucked
into
many many local feuds pre-existing foods
that were
fighting and bubbling away way before we
got there
and we were walking into an environment
we didn't understand and a conflict we
didn't understand and i think
in the end of the day we were fighting a
different war to many of the afghans
who were on the ground that were
fighting and mike
let's talk about some of course just add
on to that would that be okay
because i i was one of the few people
who spoke fluent push to
uh and i was a political officer and my
job was to try and figure some of this
stuff out
and i um went
just to illustrate and reinforce andy's
point i went to the british library
to pull up the records of the british
political officers who of course
were operating in kandahar and in
helmand
throughout the 1800s and this was in
2011 i did this this was for the
research for my phd
um i said as these as these records came
up from the stacks
i just casually asked the librarian uh
the last time
they'd been um you know when was last
time someone pulled these out
1992 was the answer
and so at that point um the uk had been
in afghanistan for 10 years
and we'd been in helmand for five or
six years and nobody had bothered to go
the five
tube stops between uh where the
mod main building is and where the
british library is
in order to do some of the research from
the previous
british contingents uh who'd been in
helmand
and of course that you think eighteen
hundred as well as ages ago who
remembers that
well we didn't remember any of it but
the helmandes
um who are well more than half of
hellmann is
illiterate when we went there it was
about 10 literacy
um they all remembered it and they all
knew
who fought the british at that time and
in fact they revered
the leaders who led the rebellions
uh if we can call them that against the
british at that time and this is
how little we understood the conflict
i think this is a very similar story
across asia as well i'm chinese myself
and
you know in east asia i think that's a
similar story of british involvement
british
amnesia about what happened but local
memory as well and andy on that china
point one thing that you point out in
your piece is that
for our next foreign engagement and you
point out that
if we're happening we're going into cold
war too that we need to understand china
better and i don't really see that many
chinese speakers around westminster
either so i don't really think those
lessons have been learned what do you
think
no i i would agree uh and i would hope
and this may sound um
extreme but i would hope that at staff
college
people are learning about confucianism
they're learning about the history
of china especially the british
involvement there which
the chinese population very much does
remember um
not least the opium wars and really
understand
how um the the chinese think and and i
don't think we are doing that
and it's not about the the traditional
know your enemy
so you can defeat your enemy it's also
about creating these opportunities for
de-escalation
and creating those opportunities to not
go to war in the first place
and mike finally i couldn't have you on
the show with and let you go without
asking you about
the taliban this is something that
you've done a lot of writing about and
how there's no such thing
as the taliban can you explain why you
know there is a problem with politicians
in the media and
people in general talking about the
taliban
yeah thank i mean thanks for giving me
the opportunity to do that
uh not not many media organizations do i
guess the spectator is on the way up
um thank you we you know as human beings
we use labels right
we use them all the time so if i say you
know the word
government that will mean something
different depending on where you live on
the planet
where you are on the left right spectrum
for instance right
and the reason labels are so important
is because they then a concept pops into
your head
and i would argue that when
you say the word taliban most people
think of
the kind of previous taliban government
um the de facto government from 96
2001 so it's kind of a cohesive
organization they've got some ministries
they've got an army
uh you know they ban music all that kind
of
islamist stuff they you know bad towards
women
and women have to wear special shoes so
they don't make noise so we've got this
kind of idea about what the taliban are
like but but the most important bit of
that idea
i would argue or the most dangerous bit
of the idea is that they are
a cohesive organization um that is
able to operate in the same way as say
i don't know the labour party in the
united kingdom
okay well arguably
but they are
know your audience but they are not
um they are not at all and so i can
go through maybe three ways in which
they're not um
there's a political office of the
taliban at the moment
in doha and these are the guys who
negotiated
the agreement with the americans in
february 2020 that's led to this
pull-out which is why we're having the
kind of situation we've got going on now
right
and the other people who met the chinese
recently as well yeah
absolutely absolutely i mean this is
what's dominating news at the moment
and then we have of course the military
wing who are doing a lot of the fighting
uh in afghanistan there's a huge amount
of divergence between those two
and you know daily you can see
statements coming from the political
wing and actions coming from the
military ring that are totally
um uh discordant so it could be a ruse
but actually i think the political wing
has totally lost control
political winger mostly from the old
taliban from the regime 96
2001 the military ring some of these
guys
some of the fighters weren't even born
when 2001 happened secondly
we have um the this idea that um
actually the the taliban is a kind of
franchise of lots of different
uh interest groups and this is
not hugely unusual i mean we do see it
in political parties you know
the conservatives might have in them say
free marketeers
and people who are culturally
conservative for instance right
and so you know the party tries to hold
them together but in
the taliban we've got really really
marked
factionalism between um already
established insurgent groups so like the
haqqanis that were insurgents well
before the taliban
we've got the helmandi taliban who are
basically locals they're sangonites
and they've got connections to iran
we've got the guys in kandahar
well they're really strongly connected
to pakistan
up in head art that's a totally
different thing
so we have a huge regionalization
uh behind what we see
and then the third type of factionism
i'd like to bring up is is really what
i explored when i was in helmand so as i
know as
as i told you i spent some time as a
political officer i then did my phd down
there
um and i picked apart
all of the reasons why people were
fighting and most of the reasons why
people were fighting were not to
establish an islamic emirate in fact
i don't think i met anyone who was
that's fighting to establish an islamic
emirate
the people were fighting because of uh
water or
they had a feud with the police chief
and this is some of the stuff andy was
bringing up
some of the conflicts we stumbled into
or because
it was a revenge killing because their
brother had been killed by coalition
forces or the canal was in the wrong
place or
or or or so there's a huge multiplicity
of reasons village to village
family to family about why people pick
up a kalashnikov
to solve their problems because there's
no effective court system in afghanistan
so the only way you can solve your
problems
is with the kalashnikov and so we've got
these three
levels of factionalization between
political and military between different
big factional insurgent groups in
different areas of afghanistan
and right at the micro level between
different villages different families
different sub clans
and it's really hard to call that a
cohesive movement that
that concept is not the same as the
concepts that we described at the
beginning when i said taliban and we
thought about the 96 to 2001 taliban
with ministries and an army and so on
and so forth
and the reason that's really important
is because as we go forward
everyone is now saying guys we've got to
stop fighting
we've got to sit down in doha the afghan
government and the taliban have got to
sit down and they've got to hammer out
some kind of
transitional government or something you
know we've got to have peace how are we
going to do this what's the process
but how can you make
peace with a movement that is so
fractured
and i i worry that we're hanging our
hats on a process that's doomed to fail
because the taliban
this concept of the taliban is not
actually
what we think it is andyoman
mike martin thanks for joining spectator
tv
remember we've got a special offer if
you subscribe to the magazine today
you can get 12 weeks off the magazine
for just 12 pounds
and we'll even throw in a free 20 pound
amazon gift voucher completely free
that's three months of the spectator
delivered to your door and available
online for just 12 pounds
and you get that 20 pound amazon voucher
to take it up just go to spectator dot
co dot uk forward slash tv offer
now back home this week scotland
welcomes boris johnson and kiyostama as
normal politics resumes
but can either man outmaneuver nicola
sturgeon i'm joined now by the
spectator's political editor james
forsyth
and by deputy political editor katie
balls james what's boris johnson's
mission in scotland
i think the prime minister is trying to
normalize him visiting
scotland in a way it's a symptom of
what's gone wrong
that a british prime minister visits
scotland
is considered newsworthy regardless of
what he does or
or says on that visit but i think this
visit also gives this idea
of the of the new phase that we're in uh
when it comes to the debate about
independence
so things have gone went very quiet
after hollywood elections
in may i think in the autumn the issue
will rise back up the agenda
as nicolas sturgeon you know you know
tries to kind of satisfy her own
activist base by moving forward on it
but i think what you're going to see is
he's almost done nice off between boris
johnson and nicholas dodge i thought it
was very revealing
but as soon as the news that boris
johnson was going to scotland leaked
nicolas sturgeon was out with a letter
to him saying
all right well i hope you'll be coming
to visit me so we can discuss all the
shared priorities
uh that we have and that's because
the polling that both sides are seeing
shows that voters in scotland want to
see
the uk government and the scottish
government working together
so you then saw boris johnson writing
back saying no no i'm not going to see
you on this visit but i want to see you
and other first ministers
uh in a in a structured forum ah
and then nicola sturgeon saying well i
think it's a bit disappointing he's
coming to scotland and
first chance post covid to sit down with
me face to face and discuss
shared priorities so i think i mean this
will be a big theme of it i think one of
the questions is
that you know can the uk government
resist
rising to every snp provocation i think
an independence bill
if one was brought to the scottish
parliament in the autumn you know would
be that
you know i mean the danger for nuclear
surgeon in bringing this bill
is that it seems an odd priority at a
time when nhs waiting lists are
are going up rapidly when uh pupils have
obviously not recovered from the
educational effects of
homeschooling in the pandemic and yeah
the criminal justice system delays
if she can turn that into a debate about
whether the scottish parliament has the
right to have this debate that suits her
a lot more and secondly one of the
things that the nationalists have done
which is one of the reasons how they
have held their movement together
is to create these these um these
rallying points
that basically says to everyone oh we
must now win this fight
rather than discussing you know uh our
own internal strategy
and a big debate between the uk
government saying oh
no this debate in scottish parliament is
illegitimate it's a infringement on
reserve powers
would give sturgeon that at a time when
her own activists are
scratchy and just look at this dispute
about what the snp did or did not spend
the money that was meant to be earmarked
for a second independence campaign
on and so i i think all of these reasons
are why
the uk government shouldn't rise to snp
provocations in the coming months
katie is boris johnson going to find
this actually quite a welcome break from
westminster politics given that he has
some
pretty bad poll numbers recently which
police can you talk us through
yes i will do and i do think it's
interesting if you think back to the
scottish palm election campaign
that we had uh there was lots of talk at
the time
uh that boris johnson was not someone
who'd be welcome to do a visit to
scotland
and because things are so tense as scott
tory's really worried
about the impact restaurants would have
given his approval ratings there
and instead i think the only man they
wanted to see there was russia sunak
so in a way i think the fact that yes he
is prime minister
um but boris johnson is visiting as a
sign of a i think a less fraught
situation
uh particularly now that election came
and went without the s p winning an
outright majority
um now i think if we move on to poll
ratings across the uk
uh as you say cindy we've had some
interesting polling out this week of
tory members
for the conservative home website i
think there were two
uh eye grabbing uh polls within that the
first was the cabinet league table
which uh is the net satisfaction ratings
of the various cabin ministers
and boris johnson has dropped quite
heavily uh
to the lower half still has a few
ministers beneath him in terms of
negative or
net satisfaction lower scale so robert
generic gavin williamson
amanda milling the party chairman but
rishi sunak
is very high and both richard c neck and
liz trust the international trade
secretary
uh the ones the highest approval ratings
now
there's one other poll which is uh the
one i think which is perhaps raising
more eyebrows which is
uh the next tory leader now there's not
currently a vacancy
but originally cena tops that poll and i
think in a week where we're hearing uh
some briefing but also we're seeing the
leak of travel letter
uh uh written by richard c neck that
went to number 10
um out in the sunday times um i think
you're getting a lot of talk that the
chancellor is on maneuvers
and now there's strong denials that
that's the case but i think polls like
this don't particularly help
and james is not just rishi cena boris
johnson nicholas surgeon who are the key
players here because kia stammer the
labour leaders
also in scotland this week and he's
visiting a wind farm can you talk us
through what he's planning
so i think for kia stammer i mean you
have to have some sort of labour revival
in scotland
for a labor majority but i think even
for labour to be the largest party in a
hung parliament he also is very aware of
the fact that if the polls
tighten ahead of the next election and
we're going into it with the result
uncertain that the tories will almost
certainly do what they did to ed
miliband to him
which is start asking will you do a deal
with the snp and this is a very
difficult
um and this really did hurt labor in
2015
and i think one of the things that
kierstan is trying to do is trying to
preempt that attack so
this week he's made clear uh that he
will not do
any deal with the snp either before or
after a general election
and i mean that's an attempt to address
that question beforehand i think there's
an interesting question about
scottish labor which is you know
everyone thought that anasawha
had a particularly impressive hollywood
election campaign you know
his personal ratings were very strong at
the end of the campaign
but in part because of a tactical voting
that went on that didn't result in
that didn't lead to a great result for
labor and so i think the question is
whether the scottish labor can kind of
manage to
rebuild themselves enough to win some
parliamentary seats
in scotland at the next election and
whether kia stammer can
can can find a way to handle this
question of
how he would behave in a hung parliament
when it came to smp and i think the line
you will hear from him is
you know no deals with the snp if they
want to let the tories in
that's up to them i think labour
strategists have decided that that is
the least
worst line because that's a line that
can work for them they think in both
england
and uh england wales and scotland
because in scotland they can point to
the fact that you know it was the snp as
uh performance in the 1979 no confidence
vote but that was one of the things that
led to margaret thatcher's election
victory and i think you know
i know that 1979 seems a long way away
but i think in the in the
battle of between the snp and labor i
think you will expect to hear labour
making that point
uh in the next election when it comes to
what would happen in hong kong
and finally katie when we're while we're
on the topic of scotland nicholas
sturgeon this week pushed
quite hard for teen uh vaccinations to
be opened up to teenagers 16 and 17 year
olds
and now the jcbi has done that so does
she know that i was coming up and is
that why she staked
her claim on that position and is she
right to do that
i mean i think she gave us a teaser as
to what was going to happen within the
next
24 hours and um i mean the way she
phrased it was the fact that she
said that she understood we could expect
there's likely to be announcements so i
think it was clearly
uh coming from information she had had
access to rather than just
hazarding a guess and it's something
we've seen it quite a few times during
the pandemic particularly in the early
stages
where there was been frustration that
you would have a meeting that nicolas
sturgeon would be at
and then westminster politicians would
be deaf surprised every time it happened
that nick of the surgeon would hold a
press conference before boris johnson
managed to get out to the podium to make
his own announcement so
i think that's a that's a general theme
and perhaps one to just to expect
and but i think on child vaccination
it's interesting because i do think
the mood music from the scottish
government is much more
i suppose positive or generally speaking
uh
you know open to this idea whereas i
think the uk government and
the westminster government it's often
been it's been a bit more muted
and i think that's partly because there
is um some debate in government
across cabinet also amongst some public
health england
as to the wisdom of uh you know
vaccinating children in terms of how
young you go the age groups but the
strong suggestion we have
um this week from the deputy chief
medical officer um jonathan van tam
is that uh ultimately this is heading
one way so younger age groups could soon
be added so you could see that over 12s
and i think that's definitely one to
watch
kt and james thanks for coming on now
vaccination may have been opened up to
16 year olds now
but the government is still facing a
problem with lack of vaccine
uptake in younger age groups now in an
attempt to rule 20 somethings
after telling them they'll be banned
from nightclubs and maybe their
university lectures too
the government is promising discounts
with uber and delivery as bribes
will it work i'm joined by rory
sutherland the spectator's wikiman
columnist
and vice chairman at the advertising
agency ogilvy
rory thanks for joining spectator tv
what do you reckon do you think this is
going to work
they probably will work i'm very
skeptical generally about mainstream
economics
but i wouldn't be so uh extreme as to
say that incentives don't work
um and those are you know those are
fairly well targeted benefits
um other interesting behavioral
scientists have also looked at the
effect of lotteries
on encouraging vaccination which is
particularly if you design a lottery in
such a way that you might end up being a
winner but knowing that you missed out
through failing to vaccinate yourself
those can also be quite powerful
incentives to encourage people
to take up a behavior when they're what
you might call on the margin
looking at this uber and delivery
discount i was a bit peeved that i've
actually
already had my first job i've got my
second job already booked in
maybe i should just delayed because my
compliance is not really being rewarded
well there is always the risk that
people game the system
a little bit or that people might
actually hold off on vaccination
waiting for a higher offer rather like
those people who refuse to sell their
house to a developer
on the grounds that if they're the last
person resisting
they'll get the best price i mean i
would argue that
some to some degree it's fair to say of
younger people
that the impetus to be vaccinated if
you're 25
is not the same impetus if you're 55.
because the the the likelihood of
fatality
is minimal from kovid
and so it's a more pro-social act
becoming vaccinated if you're young
whereas if you're older you could argue
well to some degree it's a selfish act
and therefore uh the engagement of some
sort of
additional incentive or encouragement
for young people of course it won't work
on complete anti-vaxxers it only works
at the margins
but then if you think about it
epidemiology kind of works at the
margins
in other words you don't need absolutely
everybody to be vaccinated uh in order
for
uh this thing to be killed you just need
a sufficiently high proportion of people
to effectively bring the r rate below
one
and so uh it is important to say that
you know if you can do
something via persuasion my my favorite
methods
uh of approaching a problem are first of
all try persuading people
then if that fails try bribing people
and only if that fails should you ever
consider compulsion
now the strange thing about government
is it's dominated by lawyers who
occasionally take advice from economists
and government tends to approach things
from legislation first
inducement or financial incentive second
and persuasion third
now whatever the relative merits of
those three interventions and there's a
kind of temperamental libertarian
um i always favor persuasion wherever
possible
i don't think it's difficult to make the
case that government often approaches
those things in the wrong order
what do you think persuasion looks like
in this context
when it comes to covert um i saw a
german advert last year for example
uh asking young people to stay at home
during lockdown and comparing
their efforts to their grandparents
efforts in second world war and you know
giving them sort of heroicism
to the theme i thought that was a i
thought that was a brilliant thing which
without mentioning the second world war
explicitly
what it effectively said is you know in
the past and i have made that i don't
know if i made that argument
in a similar way beforehand i said
americans are going completely bananas
about wearing masks
but i would argue that compared to being
forced to fight in the tet offensive
okay or go into the jungle being shot at
by the viet cong
i would argue that wearing a mask down
the high street of moline
is a relatively small inconvenience to
have to endure
and then the germans took this same
framing and did it rather brilliantly
which more or less said
it it had an elderly person effectively
in the future
talking about their service and it was
contrasting implicitly the difference
between being able to fight
being forced to fight the ivans on the
eastern front and merely staying at home
ordering pizzas watching netflix
and um it was incredibly funny and
charming and i think it was all the more
persuasive because it was humorous
i think one of the things that the
germans managed to do which
interestingly maybe the british didn't
was partly to use a little bit of humor
now we know you know historically humor
is a magical means just as music is in a
sense
for generating an emotional state
without some of the negatives that arise
if you try and use the sheer brute force
of reason
and you can make points humorously which
are then accepted which will be rejected
if you tried to make them in
deadly seriousness and so i thought the
germans
deserve a significant commendation for
how they handled it
and it seemed to have worked um but um
i i think it is important to remember
that many many things and i'd include
that
things like adoption of electric cars
okay we don't need everybody to adopt
electric cars
forcing people or bribing people to
adopt electric cars
unfairly punishes a lot of people who
bite into their circumstances can't or
won't adopt them
so persuasion should always be the first
mode of intervention
simply because it harvests the
low-hanging fruit
and sometimes the low-hanging fruit is
all you need
you know i've argued for ages it's just
an environmental policy look if you
encourage people to put their tumble
dryers and washing machines on later at
night
okay um that will actually reduce carbon
emissions simply because the uk is kind
of nuclear powered or powered heavily by
renewables
at ten o'clock in the evening in a way
that it isn't at five o'clock
now if you try to make that compulsory
or you use the price mechanism
what happens to people who work the
night shift they can't do it
you don't want them leaving their house
with a tumble dryer on what happens to
people who live in a flat
and their washing machine is immediately
above their neighbor's bedroom
which means it's going to hit the spin
cycle at one o'clock in the morning
those people can't do it now the great
thing with persuasion is if you've got a
good reason
you can advance that reason and you're
now immune
or freed from the obligation the second
you start using economic incentives or
legal
uh legal directives that nuance gets
completely lost
and you try and design legislation for
everybody which in some cases ends up
working for nobody
and we've only really seen that
persuasion you know you've had people
like gareth southgate making a short
video
asking young people to get vaccinated
but i've not really heard anything else
really in that persuasion side
on the other hand we have heard about
vaccine passports being coming in for
nightclubs under the thought that under
30s go to nightclubs and
this is what's going to get them to get
get jabbed what do you make of that we
had some
so mark warport who is um patrick
valenz's predecessor in the chief
scientific advisor role
on spectator tv recently and he was
calling that a nudge
i mean it feels more like a shelf yes
the vaccine passport of course it's it's
it's ambiguous in a way in that you know
i i mean the way i describe myself is a
is a default libertarian i don't
i don't accept the idea that there
aren't coordination problems i don't
accept the idea that there isn't a need
for
uh central uh um and i don't object you
know
to put it very simply i don't object to
people painting lines in the car park
okay you know there are certain you know
you know if you're an extreme
libertarian you'd say it's interfering
with my right to park at the diagonal
i don't object to that kind of thing you
know
painting white lines on the road is a
nudge if you like
okay and you know even deirdre mccloskey
who's more libertarian i think than i am
argues that there are there's a large
informational role that government can
play
which needn't involve any kind of
compulsion at all now
where does the issuing of a passport
where it's up to the private sector to
determine whether they require that
passport or not where does that sit
now to me personally and i admit
this is very very subjective to me
that's relatively uncontroversial if the
passport is being policed by private
entities who simply say i'm sorry it's
our restaurant
if you're not prepared to do this you
can't come in when it becomes employers
for example or academic institutions
you know no vac no no vacs no lecture
that gets a bit more contentious
because you can argue well you don't
necessarily have free choice there
you know you don't you can't suddenly
switch university according to their
vaccine policy and so it's complicated i
generally regard the imposition of
vaccine rules
by private institutions as broadly
speaking acceptable
it gets more contentious um if you like
when it it starts to be imposed in areas
where
i would i would argue that um
mark squaring you know i i don't really
understand the massive
descent over masks because to me you
know there are plenty of inconvenient
things like wearing underpants that i do
really you know not you know not
necessarily for my own self-interest but
simply to avoid alarming other people
and i would i would place mask wearing
in the field of courtesy
which is even if you don't believe in
them and i think they do work by the way
you know i think at some level they
undoubtedly work
but even if you don't believe in them
some people do
and it's deeply you know discourteous to
elderly people who may be alarmed by
someone
uh wandering around the shops without a
mask i think it's simply an act of
courtesy
to other people and you know it also
sits within i think you know the
reasonable realm of
um the precautionary principle you know
this might work and
generally the cost benefit uh thing
looks fairly high
when you're demanding people um are
vaccinated
who are young for example
um and there are side effects to the
vaccine uh among the young
you know they're you know they're not
particularly unpleasant for the most
part
but they're not negligible i'm getting a
bit more uncomfortable there and i might
also raise the question well
what if to be honest it isn't necessary
to hit 100
and rory just on that vactine passport
point some people have been saying that
because it's coming in in september
not immediately that actually all of it
is just a ploy for people to get
vaccinated and come september
these passports may not even come into
place but
what i wonder about that is that isn't
it quite a hit on the government's
credibility
to do that kind of u-turn to kind of
dangle this kind of threat over young
people and then rescind it as if they
never wanted to do it in the first place
i mean
that credibility hit surely in the minds
of people is actually not insignificant
well it's a very interesting question
isn't it which is how should we react to
legislation which is really exists for
its signaling value
rather than as an actual restraint on
behavior
so it acts as an accelerant it
encourages people to act fast it's
equivalent to
only four seats left at this price which
is you might as well do it now because
you'll have to do it ultimately now
as you might expect working in the
advertising industry with a strong
interest in kind of behavioral science
um legislation that i mean actually
quite a lot of legislation in a way
works that way
i mean we don't impose speed limits uh
rigorously okay we you know we we very
rarely find people for going
um 73 miles an hour and so legislation
which
uh which exists in potential but isn't
necessarily
uh enforced can have a value because it
essentially
you know it might accelerate a behavior
it might um
uh it might make corporate decision
making easier because you can say this
is going to be a legal requirement in
five years time
so we might as well start acting now all
our competitors will be doing this
so in solving coordination problems um
laws which act to send a message
rather than to actually necessarily be
enforced i would argue
actually from a libertarian point of
view fairly desirable
in a funny kind of way because they
solve the coordination problem
without necessarily limiting liberty
and so the way i always phrase it is i'm
not a pure libertarian but i'm glad such
people exist
because i think that mentality uh plays
an essential component
part in looking at
making over how government intervenes
with the populace
i'm i'm not massively sympathetic
towards anti-masters because it seems to
be a very very small price to pay
and it seems to be a slightly deranged
fear anti-vaxxers
i would seek if possible because you
know there are potential arguments
against universal vaccination
um and anti-vaxxers in that case i would
seek to find an accommodation with them
rory sutherland thanks for joining
spectator tv and finally
is it fair for a trans woman to compete
against women in sports
that whole debate has been reignited by
the participation of the 43 year old
laurel hubbard in women's weightlifting
she transitioned
a decade ago but did her physique still
give her an unfair advantage
over her female peers to discuss this
i'm joined now by suzanne moore
the telegraph columnist who left the
guardian after writing about transgender
issues
suzanne welcome to spectator tv to start
with
do you think it was fair that laurel
hubbard was competing in the women's
category
it's it's such a difficult question i
think it's i think
laurel's inclusion has really brought
this stuff to the fore
and um there are a whole number of
issues here
about laurel hubbard not just about
gender actually i think
the fact that laurel hubbard was twice
the age of
the other competitors the situation
where she took the place of a
much younger woman for for new zealand
um
i really uh not sure how much this has
done for the
argument that we should include trans
people in sports i think we should
include
trans people in sport but there are
questions of
which sports and how do we make it fair
i mean people have not made much of a
fuss about quinn
who was a medalist in the uh
in a football in olympic football
who was a trans man that hasn't grabbed
much attention at all because quinn was
competing in the female category
so it's not a question of just trying to
pick on laurel hubbard it's a question
of trying to work out
what actually is fair and i do think
sports is one of the issues
where this whole debate about
sex and gender which can can seem very
very abstract to people
becomes really visible you know
what is a man what is a woman what are
our bodies the same can we actually
change sex and
it makes those questions really really
uh
tangible to people yeah and you make the
point that
different sports we maybe do you think
that we should have different rules for
different sports depending on what we're
measuring is excellence
yeah i i i was
joking once but i put on twitter you
know if you want to be equal just
uh get on a call on a horse and learn to
ride it
um and i would say now the same about a
bmx like
since charlotte worthington you know did
that amazing stuff uh
clearly clearly there are sports where
strength um
muscle mass bone density are involved
and weightlifting
does appear to be one of them there are
other sports where perhaps
you know we can it is a more level
playing field um i think i think
i'm not sure we can just have one rule
for every sport yeah
there's an interesting amount of nuance
there because obviously some things as
you say
are more strength based but for someone
like laurel hubbard you know she
she did fail her lifts three times all
three of them so she actually didn't
do that well and for weightlifting
they'll weight categories depending on
the lifter themselves
so some people might say actually when
it comes to these categories she doesn't
seem to have that much of an
advantage because of the way well before
because of the way that she did
and also because of the way that the
sport or it's already categorized what
do you think about that
well the fact that that she failed can
be
uh used i suppose to say well she didn't
have the advantage but i think
i mean i'm no great expert on
weightlifting
but when i started to read about it
people were surprised
that she was chosen because the average
age of the weightlifter
at their peak is usually early twenties
um
and then they sort of decline so
had laurel been competing in in any
category of men
she she well she just wouldn't have
qualified at all
uh so to choose because
of her gender identity to compete with
women at that age
seemed to me a really very strange
sort of proving the point somehow and
and it did look a lot like
i mean i wrote this so i have to you
know i do things
it did look a lot like male entitlement
there and
i don't know if you saw cindy the
reaction of the three medalists when
they were interviewed yesterday
there was a historic night here uh with
laurel hubbard competing as the first
openly transgender in a uh
in a individual event i was wondering
you know what you felt about that and
what you felt that it took place
in your sport
no thank you it felt very much like
they were not happy and some people read
it as well they've been told not to say
anything
i read read it as their silence said
a lot about what they thought out there
so
well susana zeno is a very tricky topic
for people who do choose to comment on
it
so i can imagine they didn't want to
wade into that
at all regardless
and also i mean these are people aren't
they who train for years and years and
years
and this is issue of unfairness in sport
we have
in all sorts of you know doping and it's
something that
i don't think any of us are can be
completely decided or expert on because
the science itself
is divided um but there does seem
to be a clear direction now that
even the ioc are going in which is to
rewrite
the rules under which by which laurel
uh hubbard qualified which was this
measurement of testosterone
they now think it's too high they may
change it because
the argument from some doctors and
scientists is that
if you've gone through male puberty you
will always have
another kind of advantage of being able
to build muscle
and bone density it uh and so
just the measure of testosterone is is
not adequate really yeah and laurel
hubbard did and having transitioned at
the age of 33
yeah yeah yeah so oh
i mean i have real sympathy for
i think i mean there are certain
athletes we know like uh casters
signa who were born the way
they were born with naturally high
testosterone
levels um i don't think i've ever tried
to cheat
or that's just the way she is
um you know they're all this is a gray
area
um it's not just about ideology about
it's something that in terms of fairness
between men and women
we need to work out and susan you
mentioned unfairness in sport but
you know isn't sport inherently unfair
on on a biological level is for example
someone with my height
i can never be a sprinter because my
legs are just not long enough
but we accept that's okay and i would
still be competing in a women's category
and we only have male and female
categories so
there's some level of biological
unfairness that we accept so
i guess the difficulty is where do you
draw the line and what biology do you
draw the line
at i don't think we know where the lines
lie and i think the other
issue is um
that there are some sports that are
clearly dangerous uh say
for instance i would say rugby um which
involve
may involve traumatic head injury as we
know
um and i think then you have a duty of
care really to protect
um to protect women who want to play
rugby
trans women what whoever it is i i think
we
as a society that's what we should be
looking at
i think the other issue that's come up
during the olympics
so so strongly this time is the absolute
you know mental sort of pressure that
people are under um
and that they're prepared to talk about
now much more openly the mental health
issues and
in a way i mean laurel hubbard to me put
herself in a tremendously
pressurized difficult situation uh
it's quite hard to fathom really because
i don't
know whether she was there to try to
kind of represent
trans people or just herself because
she's not said very much and she's said
to be a very quiet and private person
she's not really told us very much about
it um
so she's put yeah she's put herself
under a lot of pressure
not won a medal uh i guess when it comes
to the next
olympics which you know in a few years i
imagine that science will
will have changed i i think it would be
different
i mean some people are arguing i've read
people arguing for kind of third space
almost
for trans athletes do you think that
would be a good idea
again i think it really depends on the
sport i mean i do
think that there are clearly sports
where this kind of physicality
is not um is not so relevant i mean we
know
we know women jockeys can beat men you
know what i mean we know
in cycling and there are um so i think
it really really depends
on sports that are based i guess on size
and strength and rugby and weightlifting
would be two of those
it's a bit like what you're saying
you're not going to be an olympian
because you're not only because of my
legs they're not not that's the only
reason
yeah exactly right now i know i realize
that i'm always me too
phony wasn't short in fact but never
mind um
so so there are these yeah like you say
there's inherent
differences aren't there and then
there's
these issues about what hormone
um what hormones do and how long
people have have to take hormones
for to be accepted as the gender that
they identify with and whether that then
mitigates the advantages they have yeah
some some doctors think not susan moore
thanks for joining spectator tv
and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed this episode don't forget to
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom of this video
and the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you